hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
gamespot here on the front line at San
Diego comic-con 2014 and with my new
friend William and we are at the
Sideshow Collectibles booth William what
has tried Sideshow Collectibles wow
we're pretty much a culmination of pop
culture that's the best way I can go
ahead and put it we have showcasing some
of the pieces from Hot Toys
and actually some of our pieces which
are the bulk of this so we have
everything from video games you know
Marvel DC our original court of the
deadline so it's pretty exciting stuff
so I'm excited to show you guys around
showcasing a Hot Toys Batman Arkham City
piece pretty fantastic as far as the
articulation goes not too sure yet
because it's pretty early on but again
he looks pretty amazing and with hot
toys about to see a lot of accessories a
lot of those gadgets that we saw in game
so right here what you have is our
legendary scale bust so this right here
if I'm not mistaken it's based off of
the predator the original predator so
the jungle hunter and it's fantastic so
this right now is early prototype as
well it's gonna have that shoulder
cannon see that damage on the facemask
and eventually he will light up on the
laser sight here so it's pretty cool but
the one I'm really excited about is
right around the corner and what we have
here is the elder predator now we saw
him in one of the movies and through if
I was taking through Danny Glover that
gun at the end of part 2 and he's just
fantastic I mean the detail you zoom in
you got that earring around that tusks
and he's fantastic we're pretty excited
about that his mouth is just disgusting
and awesome it's no it's it's
wonderfully disgusting I'm gonna go
ahead and agree with you on that I'm
really excited about this stuff but
we're gonna go ahead and start off with
a death wing I mean right now Wow yeah
he is absolutely fantastic I mean we
really kind of took this from the
original cinematic where he kind of
comes back and just lands on Stormwind
and just kind of destroys it
so I mean you're looking at a gigantic
piece we're hoping that it'll light up
so we want to go ahead and really kind
of get this out where you're gonna have
the light
on the on Stormwind keep so it shows
like it's on fire
a pulsating chest light and hopefully on
the mouth itself so the coop so right
here we have Kerrigan Queen of Blades
I'm assuming that this would be from
Starcraft 2 now one of the things you're
gonna notice is that jerk base these
wings are amazing and we were able to
really capture that that's sexy female
you know strength there but again she's
pretty vicious to say the least and if
I'm not mistaken this was sculpted by
Mark Newman it's beautiful no it's
absolutely fantastic I mean you guys
definitely wanted to do a 360 honours
it's great you know Kerrigan is one of
my all-time favorite video game
characters I've seen a lot of Kerrigan
but I love the blue color the blue-green
Grossberg color that she's coming out of
here in the bottom and the detail on
things like the feet and the wings and
you're right you they did capture that
really sexy confidence that the Queen of
Blades has right next to this we have
Diablo from Diablo 3 now pretty
impressive piece this is the original
version that was actually released
earlier this year it did light up at the
chest and the mouth however we might be
doing some other things with this piece
down the road can't really talk too much
about that but so we have a Christopher
Reeve Superman right here oh cool pretty
fantastic I mean that suit it was a
labor of love for one of our couldn't so
guys at work and he did a fantastic job
on that piece ladies me to look got a
Wonder Woman here we're premiering a
Power Girl right behind her and she
looks fantastic
we got a Catwoman Batgirl and the green
with envy poison ivy so
Catwoman's already up and ready for
pre-order I love the way her width is
wound around her and she's got a black
cat down there by her feet no it's
fantastic just you know one little thing
if you actually get it directly through
sideshow we have an exclusive which is a
different hand holding a bag of jewels
oh wow no so it's pretty fantastic and
bad girl I'm just as excited as everyone
else to see her cuz it's my first time
seeing her here at con so this all all
three of these pieces are actually based
off of art terms sourced and allows work
and they're just knocking it out of the
park this year with these pieces but
what makes you really special is not
only the paint job but again really
vibrant that red hair pops like nothing
we've seen before but it's also the it's
also the the plants which have been
reworked those are granny plants were
not found in the original one and
they're brand-new they're pretty
fantastic and she's also available for
pre-order as well and if you see on the
side these panels are actually going to
light up the base lights up and it's
pretty accurate it's a fantastic piece I
think if that was in my house I would
just try to mock the Bounty Hunter Leia
voice all the time and annoy the heck
out of anyone who came over well I think
you'd probably have to get rid of your
fridge to get this guy in there but I
think we'll go ahead and figure it out
if you win it is a worthy sacrifice no
fridge for Han Solo so really excited
again as Lizardman boy than I am it's
very easy to go ahead and talk about
these pieces but on the right we have
Jim Raynor in his full exosuit and right
next one we have Tychus Findlay we just
put ty cuss out yesterday if I'm not
mistaken so really details
these aren't statues what's really
exciting about this is these are six
scale figures with about 96 points of
articulation no way now what that means
for you guys at home is pretty much that
the fingers will actually move at the
joints no way even the fingers even
fingers you're also gonna have light-up
features inside the helmet the turbines
on the back and if I'm not mistaken
these two canisters up front also pop
out with a light-up feature so we're
really excited I believe Jim Raynor is
already ready for pre-order tyke his
Finley though not just yet but we're
pretty excited for both these pieces
so right here from the movies we got uh
Chris Evans and mr. Hemsworth as Thor
and Captain America pretty excited about
these pieces showcasing them here this
year as we were talking earlier with
Thor that that Cape is going to be cloth
so it's not going to Polly stone you're
gonna be able to kind of pose it in some
different ways to kind of give it a more
dynamic feel to it it's amazing I love
that cape so here we got a couple of
hulks
these guys are not small to say the
least so on the Left we have the Red
Hulk what's really great about this is
that we're doing a total of three hulks
that are similar so we have a green a
gray and a red but even though they're
all holtz they're all going to be very
unique so the gray one will have more a
larger brow so it's definitely
reminiscent to some of the older designs
and then the green our obi-wan Kenobi
and legendary scale figure I'm not too
sure if it went up for pre-order but
what's really exciting about this is
number one that sculpt on the head of
Alan Guinness is fantastic it looks just
like him now I believe we are going to
have a switch out right hand so what's
exciting about this bar collect is that
we're going to have a full lightsaber
Wow that will light up dr. doom here and
what's really great about him number one
he's massive all that is going to be
cloth
you know the robing the belts the
buckles on the actual suit up here are
actually metal so we're definitely not
skimping on materials here we want to
make sure that he is not only massive
but he really is as accurate as possible
oh cool so it's really cool as a fully
sculpted you need to start up underneath
there and it's pretty fantastic so you
guys are seen that here first
so it's really cool about this is this
this is pretty much from the creative
minds at sideshow so cool this is all us
through and through these are not just
beautiful works of art but there's also
going to be stories and lore behind all
these characters sit here which one
would you say is your favorite
collectible in here my favorite a you're
gonna see a bit of a trend on me I
definitely love strong beautiful women
I'm gonna go ahead and show you guys the
queen of the Dead she's actually ready
for pre-order and she looks fantastic
hands down one of my favorite pieces of
the line Wow that headpiece is really
cool very cool so much excitement and
fandom and all that if if you guys
aren't here at comic-con then how can
they come in and find out more about
Sideshow Collectibles well a couple
options if you want to go ahead and
start ordering and collecting it's a
slippery slope but it's a fun ride
sideshow calm now if you want to learn
more about the Court of the Dead also
really easy its Court of the Dead calm
we're really excited about all this
awesome I'm gonna do some browsing of my
own maybe get one of my own temporary
tattoos here let me know what you
thought of Sideshow Collectibles and
whether you're going to be pre-ordering
some things like I am tweet at me at
Anna Prosser